einen nagelneuen radweg gibt es zwischen
dem bayerischen eschenberg und miesbach
direkt an der viel befahrenen
bundesstraße 472 doch die radfahrer die
sich eigentlich über den 400.000 euro
teuren weg freuen müssten sind
stinksauer denn bei dem kurzen teilstück
fehlt an beiden seiten der anschluss er
endet vorne und hinten mitten im
gefährlichen verkehrsgewühl der
bundesstraße eigentlich total verarscht
vor weil leute dann so plötzlich wieder
aufhört und so kurz bloß wegen der bis
dahin super enttäuscht man geht auf den
radweg und plötzlich ist er aus
katastrophe einmal daher der aufschlag
auf das ich mir sicher da vorne und dann
stehst du dann muss er erst mal stehen
bleiben wollte man in autos kommen bist
du wieder auf die straße raus kommst und
dann geht es wieder los
die bundesstraße wurde hier umgebaut um
sie sicherer zu machen eine gute idee
einen radweg hat man gleich mitgebaut
aber gerade mal 700 meter lang
dann endet der schmucken neubau einfach
und es wird gefährlich
hier müssen sich die radfahrer einfädeln
auf die viel befahrene straße ein paar
meter weiter ist es noch enger radeln
entlang dieser stützmauer
lebensgefährlich beim staatlichen bauamt
sieht man darin keiner fehlplanung
entscheidende punkt war eigentlich das
haus löse für die baumaßnahme der
verkehrssichere ausbau der b 472 war
und insofern der gerade in diesem
bereich eigentlich nur ein nebenprodukt
war
aha ein nebenprodukt für 400.000 euro
und so bald wird sich daran auch nichts
ändern
das land muss erstmal die grundstücke
kaufen und dann mit den planungen
beginnen die chance also dass aus dem
teuren nebenprodukt in absehbarer zeit
ein sinnvoller und vor allem sicherer
radweg wird verschwindend gering
das ist richtig wir werden schon noch
ein paar jahre brauchen ein paar jahre
lang
also eine unübersichtliche und
lebensgefährliche situation für
radfahrer muss also ständig die straße
queren das ist gerade bei diesen verkehr
hier schon sehr gefährlich
deswegen ist eigentlich der radweg denen
die jetzt neu gebaut haben
für die katz einfach sinnlos völlig
überflüssig 400.000 euro für einen
radweg von nürnberg nach miesbach der
gefährlich ist und keinem nützt da hat
sich wohl das staatliche bauamt bayern
gründlich verfahren